do you think the first scene or sort of
sentence
in a screenplay is as important the way
maybe the first sentence in a novel
would be that's a good question i
haven't thought about it but um i would
say no
only because i think in a novel well i
don't know when you're reading a novel
you're going to give it more than one
sentence
right i mean if you've picked up a novel
to read
you're you're probably pretty interested
in it already
um in a screenplay i have
heard so it depends on the situation uh
if i
am reading this entire script and i
already know i'm reading it front to
back
then that first sentence if it's clunky
i'm
i'm gonna give it a little bit of leeway
i'm going to give it another chance
right so i'm going to keep reading
regardless
um i have heard some people say
that they can tell if they're going to
keep reading a script
from the first sentence if they read the
first sentence and they're not hooked or
it feels like the person doesn't really
know what they're doing
then they're gonna put it down i would
say that's an extreme that's an extreme
opinion
um but you know you also have to
understand that if we're talking about a
situation where you are submitting your
script to be read by
somebody in the industry you're asking
for their time
right um how much time they're willing
to give you
is up to them so the best thing you can
do is make sure that every sentence of
your screenplay
is worth reading and makes them want to
read the next one right that's
you have to set yourself up for success
um because there's no guarantee that
they're going to read your whole script
that's fair right and then this is by
the way you said you're you're hearing
this from
producers or agents or whatever you've
heard this is not necessarily your
opinion
right but it's just yes i mean i very
rarely
pick up a script just to read one
sentence and see if i like it or not
um but you know it depends on the
situation so if
if someone is a if someone's reading a
lot of scripts if they're
vetting scripts for a producer say and
they're just looking for something
really
great they might they might only give it
a page or two pages they might
you know um back in the day when i was
reading a lot of scripts for a producer
and so it wasn't
i wasn't reading the scripts to try to
give notes and help make them better i
wasn't working on a project it was just
vetting projects to see if there was
anything interesting or worth reading
the whole script
um you know it wasn't uncommon to read
the first act
or even read to where the inciting
incident
should be and see if anything's
happening see if there's anything
to like sort of catch my interest and
make me want to keep reading this script
so
um i think if you're submitting your
scripts to producer
or a manager an agent you should assume
that you need to hook their attention
you know
at least in the first few pages if not
on the first
page itself and this goes back to the
the story that you said about
being from oregon and you know hey how's
it going when you're working at a
production company
really and then and and when you called
the los angeles area
it was more protocol for them to just
kind of be like yeah what do you need
yeah well-intentioned i'm sure they are
but but
that's the tempo of of the industry and
it wasn't to
find out you know how your day was going
yes exactly the the pace in la that's
what surprised me
when you know comparing oregon to
california
uh from portland to la the pace is
definitely a lot faster and that took
some getting used to
but yes i think that speaks to that's
exactly right like people
working in the industry are short on
time and there's a lot of material to
get through and so
you have to make your material grab them
and
and make them want to keep reading and
that's that's a challenge you know
you